three two one
so
well there we are quite a tribute the
public first responding
with cash with all that cash for
the nhs and now responding with uh
applause and it is well deserved for a
very special man let's just bring in
uh panisha
which boris johnson said he supported uh
talk
of a of a statue uh
for uh captain tom moore that's right
boris johnson called
captain settle more a hero in the truest
sense of the world a beacon of hope for
the world
as well and i think everyone will want
to share their deepest
condolences and and sympathies tonight
and we're seeing right now outside the
harrogate foundation
college and captain sir tom moore was
made an honorary colonel
at the army foundation college he was
there in september
last year carrying out an inspection at
a graduation parade with
junior soldiers as well and seeing
scenes there of
the soldiers
[Applause]
and even on the day of his birthday the
raf performed a fly past
outside his house as well but boris
johnson earlier today
talked about the spirit of optimism that
he showed
and not just in this country but across
the world
as well yeah a lovely touch
for captain tom moore the nation
out and applauding a very special man